I think actually the real world is
acquiescing to the crazy snowflakes
and we had another incident on campus
there's a guy at Oklahoma State his name
is chubby Hubbard he's a football player
I take it I don't know anything about
Oklahoma State football I don't know
anything about Java Hubbard but Java
Hubbard was very upset because the coach
for the team was photographed wearing an
O a n t-shirt you know oh and I go on O
a and all the time o an is a
conservative news channel president
Trumbull loves
Oh a any tweets about how much he likes
it at Liz wheeler is is one of the hosts
on o en you know we've had Liz wheeler
on this show so he's wearing the t-shirt
of a conservative news channel and this
player this 21 year old punk chubba
Hubbard tweets out quote I will not
stand for this this is completely
insensitive to everything going on in
society and it's unacceptable I will not
be doing anything with Oklahoma State
until things change good I hope you
don't I hope he doesn't do anything I
hope his resignation from the team is
not only accepted but requested because
his behavior is outrageous and we're now
at a point in this country where 21 year
old punks can demand that their coaches
get fired for wearing t-shirts that say
what I like a conservative news channel
that could happen to any of us any
person who mentions though you know I
watched Fox News the other day oh I
watched Oh a n the other day oh I
watched the daily wire the other day
right oh cabin to any of us of course
that's not really what happened though
they they refused to take a hard line on
this I thought they were gonna fire the
coach they didn't do that by the way
they got the kid I don't even use
American he's a Canadian he might also
be American but I thought a Canada so
you've now got this Canadian guy coming
down and trying to get Americans fired
for liking conservative TV channels you
got a kind of forced apology from the
coach yesterday this part was really
humiliating forward to making some
changes excuse me sorry I just had try
to keep my morning coffee down watching
that pathetic pathetic example now at
least the coach didn't apologize for
wearing the t-shirt of a conservative
news channel I guess then we'd all have
to apologize any of you anybody watching
on The Daily wire or listening on The
Daily wire or reading the de la wire
would have to apologize like they did
something wrong but so fortunately he
didn't go quite that far but he said
he's gonna change and he realizes it
sends him what's sensitive we're the
t-shirt
there's nothing sensitive about wearing
that t-shirt you don't need to change
anything about wearing that t-shirt what
needs to change is this presumptuous
Punk trying to get you fired for having
a political view that he disagrees with
now that presumptuous Punk for his end
did also sort of apologize in the second
part of this video which was much better
in the first part of this video
[Music]
and I'm more about action so that was
bad on my part
but from that one we're gonna focus on
breaking change and that's the most
important thing okay until the last like
three words I actually really liked this
he's right he shouldn't have sent that
tweet if he had a problem with the coach
he should have gone to the coach like a
man it's bad that's on him okay I
actually I give the kid credit for
saying all those things not sure he
wanted to say those things clearly
someone was filming it but at least he
did it he gets credit for that but then
at the end he goes we're gonna make
change what Jay what change that's the
most important thing no the most
important thing is for you to play
football and maybe go to class a few
times and get your degree you're a
student athlete do that be a student
learn things throw the ball then when
you graduate if you want to run for the
Senate go run for the Senate that's fine
these days frankly that Kittel probably
is probably better than half the
Senators which is really unfortunate but
college football college sports is not
the place to do that not every aspect of
society needs to be hopelessly
politicized and ginned up to level 11
not everything you do not wearing a
stupid t-shirt of a TV channel you like
needs to be a major political statement
where you could lose your job for it
okay the way they've left this is
basically at a truce they should have
left it if we wanted to actually have a
decent effect on the culture where the
coach was totally right and the kid was
booted from the team but that's probably
not gonna happen
[Music]
you
[Music]